Carl King has a spare bedroom in his house in Crown Heights, Brooklyn that's filled with court transcripts and police reports. There's a stack next to his bed, too, maybe 1,000 pages high. The case that he's working on right now is a murder, and the crime scene photos are kind of hard to look at-- a young woman, dead and bloody in the back of a store. The police think that she was murdered in a robbery, but Carl has his own theory.
卡尔·金在布鲁克林皇冠高地的家中有一个备用卧室，里面堆满了法庭记录和警方报告。床边也堆着一摞，大约有一千页。他现在经手的案子是一起谋杀案，犯罪现场的照片让人不忍直视——一位年轻女性死在店后的血泊中。警方认为她是因抢劫被杀，但卡尔有他自己的理论。
This murder occurred behind certain doors where the manager would be doing the operation, the daily operation, so this is certainly someone knew about this store and the full operation. It has to be an inside job.
这起谋杀案发生在经理进行日常运营的门后，所以这绝对是了解这家店及其全部运营情况的人干的。这一定是一起内鬼作案。
Carl King's not a detective. He's not a lawyer. He's just a guy who takes on cases that the police think they've already solved-- Cases where somebody has already been locked away in prison, but where Carl King thinks they got the wrong guy. Like this case.
卡尔·金不是侦探，也不是律师。他只是一个接手那些警方认为已经结案的案子的人——那些有人已经锒铛入狱，但卡尔·金认为他们抓错人的案子。就像这起案子一样。
We got this case approximately two years ago. And we're actually reinvestigating the case, you know, to overturn this conviction to give this young man back his life, actually. I got involved looking into these type of cases where guys are wrongfully accused based on a friend of mine was actually in that type of situation where he was accused wrongfully.
我们大约两年前接手了这个案子。实际上我们正在重新调查，试图推翻判决，让这个年轻人重获新生。我之所以开始调查这类冤案，是因为我的一个朋友也曾身陷囹圄，被冤枉了。
To save his friend, Carl taught himself how to read court records and find witnesses. He has a special gift for convincing people who normally wouldn't talk to the law that it's the right thing to testify. In fact, his lack of official training might be his biggest advantage in these cases.
为了救朋友，卡尔自学了如何查阅法庭记录和寻找证人。他有一种特殊的天赋，能说服那些通常不愿与警方配合的人，让他们意识到出庭作证是正确的事情。事实上，他缺乏正式培训反而可能是他处理这些案件时最大的优势。
Today on our program, the story of how he got into this line of work, how he saved his friend, how a complete amateur cracked the case that the New York criminal justice system-- some of the most experienced detectives and lawyers in the world-- couldn't crack. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
今天我们的节目，将讲述他是如何投身于这份工作，如何救出他的朋友，以及一个完全的业余爱好者是如何破解了纽约刑事司法系统——包括世界上经验最丰富的侦探和律师——都无法破解的案件的。这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》。
The story you're about to hear today happens in two acts. The first act is tragedy. The second act is redemption. The first half of this story is like this slow motion train wreck. A teenager tells a lie that sets this process in motion where one bad thing happens after another after another, getting worse and worse until an innocent man-- a complete stranger to this teenager-- ends up incarcerated for years.
你今天即将听到的故事分为两幕。第一幕是悲剧，第二幕是救赎。故事的前半部分就像一场慢动作的火车事故。一个青少年撒了一个谎，启动了一个过程，导致坏事接二连三地发生，情况越来越糟，直到一个无辜的陌生人为此入狱多年。
In the second half, an unlikely group of people come together and simply decide that they're going to set things right and teach themselves how. It's really something. We'll get back to Carl King halfway through our story. Let's start with the crime.
在后半部分，一群意想不到的人走到了一起，简单地决定要纠正错误，并自学了如何做到这一点。这真的了不起。我们将在故事中段回到卡尔·金。让我们从犯罪开始讲起。
Our story begins in 1980 in the Flatbush neighborhood of Brooklyn among people Carl didn't even know back then. Anya Bourg investigated the story.
我们的故事始于 1980 年布鲁克林的弗拉特布什社区，在那群卡尔当时甚至都不认识的人中间。安雅·布尔格调查了这个故事。
On April 10, 1980, Martell Hamilton was standing outside his junior high school. He was yelling up at his girlfriend in a school window when a kid named Thomas Charlemagne came riding up on his bike. Thomas was 14 years old, and he was the kind of kid who tags around with older kids, trying to fit in, eager to be liked. Martell was a year older than Thomas and remembers it this way.
1980 年 4 月 10 日，马特尔·汉密尔顿正站在他的初中校门外。他正对着学校窗户里的女朋友大喊，这时一个叫托马斯·查理曼的孩子骑着自行车过来。托马斯 14 岁，是个喜欢跟在年龄大的孩子后面、试图融入集体、渴望被人喜欢的孩子。马特尔比托马斯大一岁，他是这样回忆当时的：
He called me by my nickname, which was Johnny. So he said, Johnny, Johnny, your brother got shot. Your brother got shot. And I said, what? And he said, your brother Mario got shot. And he said, Johnny, I saw what happened.
他叫了我的绰号，也就是“约翰尼”。他说：“约翰尼，约翰尼，你弟弟中枪了。你弟弟中枪了。”我说：“什么？”他说：“你弟弟马里奥中枪了。约翰尼，我看到了发生的一切。”
Remember those words, "I saw what happened." They start a chain reaction that in the end takes over 21 years to undo, and they're completely untrue.
记住这句话，“我看到了发生的一切”。这开启了一连串连锁反应，最终花费了 21 年时间才得以逆转，而这些话完全是虚构的。
I think he only told me that so that maybe trying to make me feel better, and trying-- thinking that he's being helpful, you know? But he only-- you know, instead of being helpful, ended up creating a disaster.
我想他告诉我这些只是想让我感觉好受点，他以为自己在帮忙，你知道吗？但他不仅没有帮忙，反而酿成了一场灾难。
Martell followed Thomas Charlemagne, and they ran back to the scene of the crime.
马特尔跟着托马斯·查理曼跑回了案发现场。
So as I got there, I saw my brother bleeding, you know, heavily. And I felt like I was outside of my body because I couldn't believe, you know, that my brother was really shot. He was bleeding so profusely from his eye and his nostrils, and they asked me, do you know who this is? And I told them, yes, that's my brother. And they asked me how old he was, and I told them how old he was.
当我到达时，我看到我弟弟流了好多血。我感觉自己灵魂出窍了，因为我不相信我弟弟真的中枪了。他的眼睛和鼻孔流血不止。他们问我：“你知道他是谁吗？”我说：“是的，那是我弟弟。”他们问我他多大，我告诉了他们。
And then next question they asked me, you know, do you know would want to shoot your brother? And I said, no, I don't. And I said, but this guy-- my friend here said he saw what happened. And from that moment on, they held on to Thomas Charlemagne as a witness.
接着他们问的下一个问题是：“你知道谁会想射杀你弟弟吗？”我说：“不知道。”但我说：“但我朋友刚才说他看到了发生的一切。”从那一刻起，他们就紧抓着托马斯·查理曼作为证人。
The police put the boys in the back of a patrol car, and they took them to the station. They escorted Thomas Charlemagne to an interrogation room to question him, and they told Martell the news that his brother Mario had died. No one talked to him. No one asked how he was doing. No one told him where his family was. They simply sat him in a chair to wait outside the room where Thomas Charlemagne was being interviewed. Martell remembers Detective Wasser, the lead detective in the case, as a lumbering white guy who yelled a lot. And from where he was sitting, he could overhear Thomas's entire interrogation.
警察把这两个男孩塞进警车带回了警局。他们把托马斯·查理曼带进审讯室进行盘问，并告诉马特尔他弟弟马里奥已经死了。没人跟马特尔说话，没人问他状况如何，也没人告诉他家人在哪里。他们只是让他坐在椅子上，在托马斯·查理曼接受审讯的房间外等待。马特尔记得瓦瑟警探，那个案子的主审侦探，是个体型臃肿、经常咆哮的白人。从他坐的地方，他能听到托马斯受审的全部内容。
What I heard was he raised his voice at Thomas. Did you see did you see this guy with a gun? And Thomas said, no, I don't-- I don't see him with a gun. So he was like, how do you mean you don't see him with a gun? If he shot him, you got to see a gun. Did you see a gun? Like-- and he-- you can hear Thomas's voice quivering, like, yeah, I-- I guess so. I guess so. Yeah, I did see-- I did see him with a gun. Yeah, I did see him with a gun.
我听到他对着托马斯大声咆哮：“你看到那个拿着枪的人了吗？”托马斯说：“没，我没看到他拿着枪。”他就像是在说：“你怎么会没看到他拿着枪？如果他射杀了他，你肯定看到了枪。你看到枪了吗？”托马斯的声音都在颤抖：“对，我想是的，我想是的。是的，我看到了……我确实看到他有枪。是的，我看到他有枪。”
In the neighborhood, Martell says, Thomas had a reputation for lying. For instance, he told Martell's friends he was from Jamaica because they were from Jamaica, when in fact he was from Haiti. But the police didn't know any of that, and they kept 14-year-old Thomas in a room for hours on end, grilled him, showed him photo after photo, until at some point he did the only thing he knew how to do to end it. He pointed at a photo at random. The unlucky guy whose photo he picked was a man named Collin Warner.
马特尔说，托马斯在社区里以撒谎成性而闻名。比如，他告诉马特尔的朋友他是牙买加人，因为他们是牙买加人，但实际上他来自海地。但警察对此一无所知，他们把 14 岁的托马斯关在房间里数小时，不断拷问，不断让他看照片，直到最后他为了结束这一切，做了唯一能做的事：他随意指了一张照片。那个倒霉蛋就是科林·华纳。
The next day, the police gave the same treatment to Martell. Detective Wasser came by his house and sat him at the kitchen table. Martell was 15.
第二天，警察对马特尔也如法炮制。瓦瑟警探来到他家，让他坐在餐桌旁。马特尔当时 15 岁。
Then he laid out four photos on the table, like how you would lay cards out evenly across. And he said, take a look at these photos. Do you know any of these guys? And I said, no, I don't. So he said, you sure you don't know none of these guys? He said, look again. And I looked at the photo, and I said, no, I don't know any of these guys.
他把四张照片摊在桌子上，像摊开纸牌一样。他说：“看看这些照片。你认识他们中的任何人吗？”我说：“不认识。”他说：“你确定不认识他们中的任何一个？再看看。”我看了照片，说：“不，我不认识他们中的任何一个人。”
Now mind you, I was still crying at the time when he was asking me these questions. And he said what about this guy right here? Then he took Collin Warner's photo and pushed it out of the lineup and let it stick above the other three photos. And he said, you don't know this guy? You don't-- you ever seen this guy before? And I said, I might have. I might have seen him before. And the only reason why I told him that was because, you know, he just kept badgering me. And I just wanted him to stop, so I told him what he wanted to hear. And he said, well, that's the guy that shot your brother. And then he took up the four photos, and then he walked out of the house.
请记住，他在问我这些问题时，我还在哭。他说：“那这个人呢？”然后他拿出科林·华纳的照片，从那一排里推出来，让它突出在其他三张照片上方。他说：“你不认识这个人吗？你……你以前见过这个人吗？”我说：“我可能见过。”我之所以这么说，是因为他一直在纠缠我。我只想让他停下来，所以我说了他想听的。他说：“好吧，就是这个人射杀的你弟弟。”然后他收起照片，走出了房子。
Thomas Charlemagne's original lie was rapidly becoming the truth. And remember, Thomas was just 14. Once he started lying to the cops, he acted like any kid caught in a lie. He elaborated on his story, which only made things worse.
托马斯·查理曼最初的谎言很快变成了真相。记住，托马斯当时才 14 岁。一旦他开始对警察撒谎，他就表现得像任何一个被困在谎言中的孩子一样。他不断完善他的故事，这只会让事情变得更糟。
He told the cops that Mario talked to him as he lay dying, that the shooter waved the gun in his face before he ran away. It started sounding like something out of a bad cop movie, but the police believed it, and they rushed several miles down Flatbush Avenue to arrest the guy in a photo, Collin Warner.
他告诉警察，马里奥临死前和他说了话，射手在跑开前曾把枪在他面前晃过。这听起来像是一部烂警匪片的台词，但警察相信了，他们急忙开车沿着弗拉特布什大道冲去，逮捕了照片里的人——科林·华纳。
OK. This is the block I used to live on. I used to live 801 Prospect Place.
好的。这是我以前住的街区。我以前住在展望广场 801 号。
So you were living here with your mom?
所以你当时和你妈妈住在这里？
Yeah. I was living there with my mom on the second floor.
是的，我和我妈妈住在二楼。
This is Collin Warner. That day, at the moment he was supposedly shooting Mario Hamilton, he'd been driving around with friends, enjoying one of the first nice days that spring. And later, he played basketball in the park. He got home at 1:00 or 2:00 in the morning.
这是科林·华纳。在那天，在据称他枪杀马里奥·汉密尔顿的时候，他正和朋友们开车兜风，享受着那个春天难得的好天气。后来他还在公园里打了篮球。他凌晨 1 点或 2 点才回家。
When I came home, though, my mother answered the door. And she's all red in the face, hysterical, asks me, where was you-- where were you that morning? And what did you do? And the police was at the house looking for me about half an hour ago and said they wanted to talk to me about a murder. You know, so she told me to call them.
不过当我回家时，我妈妈开了门。她满脸通红，神情激动，问我：“你那天早上在哪儿？你干了什么？”警察半小时前还在家里找我，说他们想找我谈谈一起谋杀案。她叫我给他们回电话。
I call them, and I spoke to a Detective Wasser because he left his card. And he tells me all he wanted to do was to talk to me in connection with a homicide that day. And I tell him, what you want to talk to me about when I never kill nobody? I never saw no murder. He said, no, we just want to talk. So I hanged up the phone on him.
我打了电话，和瓦瑟警探通话，因为他留了名片。他说他只是想和我谈谈那天发生的一起杀人案。我告诉他：“我从来没杀过人，也没见过谋杀案，你找我谈什么？”他说：“不，我们只是想谈谈。”于是我就挂断了电话。
Remember, Colin was 18, a Rastafarian teenager in army fatigues with dreadlocks down his back. His mom made him call back.
记住，科林当时 18 岁，是一个留着长发辫、身穿军用迷彩裤的拉斯塔法里教徒。他妈妈让他回了电话。
They came, came up to the apartment, you know, and they want to take me down to the precinct. I said, for what? They said, just for questioning. And they led me-- they led me down the stairs, and when I came in the car, then they put on the handcuffs. And that was that.
他们来了，上了公寓，说要把我带到警局。我说：“为了什么？”他们说：“只是问话。”他们带我下楼，当我上了车，他们就给我戴上了手铐。事情就是这样。
You never came back here?
你从此再没回过这里？
Never came back till 21 years later.
再也没回来过，直到 21 年后。
The police took Collin to the same station where, hours earlier, Thomas Charlemagne had identified him out of a mug book as the murderer of Mario Hamilton. At the time, Collin had only been living in the states a couple of years. He immigrated from Trinidad with his family in 1978. He told the police where he'd been all day. They called his friends, who are now his alibis, to question them. But early the next morning, they booked him for murder and sent him to Rikers Island, just north of New York City.
警察把科林带到了几个小时前托马斯·查理曼在照片册中指认他为谋杀马里奥·汉密尔顿凶手的同一个警察局。当时科林才在美国住了几年。他 1978 年随家人从特立尼达移民过来。他告诉警察他全天都在哪里。他们给当时能为他作证的朋友打了电话询问。但第二天一大早，他们就以谋杀罪逮捕了他，并将他送往纽约市北部的赖克斯岛监狱。
I don't know, man. It's just-- this just happened out of the blue, and a lot of people saying like, man, you have to have known something. You understand what I'm saying? I said, I don't know nothing. It just happened. One day I was free. The next day I was locked up.
我不知道，伙计。这完全是突如其来的，很多人说：“伙计，你肯定知道点什么。”你明白我的意思吗？我说：“我什么都不知道。事情就这么发生了。有一天我还是自由的，第二天就被关起来了。”
Every few weeks, Collin would be dragged in for court hearings he didn't understand. He'd come before the bench. The judge would say a few things in legalese that didn't make it any clearer, and then he'd go back to his cell. It all felt completely random.
每隔几周，科林就会被带去参加他不理解的法庭听证会。他站在被告席前，法官用一些法律术语说几句话，事情也没变得更清楚，然后他又被带回牢房。这一切感觉完全是随机的。
Meanwhile, back in Flatbush where the shooting took place, most of the neighborhood knew that Collin was innocent. The kid who died, Mario, was from Jamaica, and so was everybody that he and his brother hung around with. To them it seemed crazy that a Trinidadian like Collin-- a Trini, as they called him-- would have had anything to do with this murder. The groups didn't mix. Mario and his Jamaican friends didn't hang with Rastas like Collin. Collin wasn't even from the neighborhood. And word on the street was that the kid who died was shot by one of his friends, a guy named Norman Simmonds.
与此同时，在发生枪击案的弗拉特布什，大部分社区居民都知道科林是无辜的。死去的孩子马里奥是牙买加人，他和他的兄弟交往的所有人也都是。对他们来说，像科林这样一个特立尼达人——他们称之为“特立尼达人”——会和这起谋杀案有任何关系简直是疯了。不同群体之间不怎么来往。马里奥和他的牙买加朋友不和科林这种拉斯塔法里教徒混在一起。科林甚至不是那个社区的人。街头传言说，死去的孩子是被他的朋友之一——一个叫诺曼·西蒙兹的家伙开枪打死的。
Norman hadn't kept his plans much of a secret. The day of the shooting, he saw Mario's brother Martell and told him he was looking for Mario, that he was going to kill him as revenge for the murder of a kid named Spangler. When Martell was questioned by the police, he told the cops about it. It's in the police report. Here's Martell.
诺曼并没有刻意隐藏他的计划。枪击发生那天，他看到了马里奥的兄弟马特尔，并告诉他自己在找马里奥，说要为名叫斯潘格勒的孩子被杀一事报仇，杀掉马里奥。当马特尔接受警察询问时，他告诉了警察这件事。这记录在警方的报告里。马特尔当时在场。
That same night when he laid out those cards on the dining table and when I was crying and he was saying to me, take a look at these guys, see if you recognize-- I said, but you know, this guy Norman told me he was going to shoot my brother. And, forget about Norman. Norman has nothing to do with this. I want you take a look at these guys. Look at these guys and see if you recognize a face. And that was the attitude from there. I didn't want to know anything about Norman.
就在那天晚上，当他在餐桌上摆开那些照片时，我在哭，他在对我说：“看看这些人，看你认不认识……”我说：“但你知道，诺曼告诉我他要射杀我弟弟。”他说：“别管诺曼。诺曼和这事没关系。我要你看看这些人，看看能不能认出一张脸。”当时就是那种态度。我不想知道任何关于诺曼的事。
Police reports show that over the next two weeks, two other teenagers also told the police about Norman and gave them the name of an eyewitness. But it took the police six months to act on the information. Then in late 1980, they finally arrested Norman Simmonds for Mario Hamilton's murder. You'd think this would have been good news for Collin, but here's how he heard about it.
警方报告显示，在接下来的两周内，另外两名青少年也向警方提供了关于诺曼的信息，并给出了一个目击者的名字。但警察花了六个月才采取行动。直到 1980 年底，他们才最终逮捕了诺曼·西蒙兹，指控他杀害马里奥·汉密尔顿。你可能以为这对科林来说是个好消息，但听听他是怎么知道的。
Some time in November I went to court. And when they call our case, it was not-- it was now Collin Warner and Norman Simmonds. So when he went back to the bullpen, I asked him, like, who are you? You know what I'm saying? He said, I'm Norman. You know, they have me for the-- for killing Mario. So I said, I'm here for killing Mario, too. And he said, but how is-- how is that? I said, listen, man. I don't know what the hell is going on. I'm here for six months now. You understand what I'm saying? And that was it. That was the whole beginning. Every day at every court date after that, we were together. Didn't see no difference between him or me.
11 月的某一天我去了法院。当我们案子被叫到时，已经变成了“科林·华纳和诺曼·西蒙兹”。当我回到拘留室时，我问他：“你是谁？你明白我的意思吗？”他说：“我是诺曼。他们抓我是为了……为了杀马里奥的事。”我说：“我也是因为杀马里奥被抓的。”他说：“那怎么会这样？”我说：“听着，伙计，我不知道到底发生了什么。我在这儿已经六个月了。你明白我的意思吗？”就这样，这就是一切的开始。从那以后的每一次庭审，我们都在一起。我看不出我和他有什么区别。
It took a year and a half more for the trial to begin. One of the reasons it took so long was that the only witness, Thomas Charlemagne, refused to testify. It wasn't until he was picked up on a robbery charge that he agreed.
审判开始又花了一年半。拖延这么久的原因之一是唯一的证人托马斯·查理曼拒绝出庭作证。直到他因抢劫罪被抓，他才同意出庭。
The trial went well for Collin. 11 jurors moved to acquit. One held out for a conviction. It was a hung jury, so the prosecution offered a plea bargain-- a two to six year sentence for Norman Simmonds, and if he accepted, Collin would walk. His story-- this story-- would end right here. It's a bizarre moment. Norman, who's only 18 and actually guilty, gets to decide both their futures-- the fate of the innocent in the hands of the guilty.
审判对科林进展顺利。11 名陪审员倾向于判无罪，只有一人坚持认为有罪。这是一个陷入僵局的陪审团，于是检察官提出了认罪辩诉协议——给诺曼·西蒙兹两年到六年的刑期，如果他接受，科林就能自由。他的故事本可以在这里结束。这是一个极其荒诞的时刻。年仅 18 岁且确实有罪的诺曼，决定了他们两个的未来——无辜者的命运掌握在罪犯手中。
They told Norman to think about it. So they sent us back to the bullpen area in the back. You know I mean-- And he asked me what should he do? I said, listen man, you shouldn't ask me that. That should be your decision.
他们让诺曼考虑一下。于是他们把我们带回后方的拘留区。你知道我的意思吗？他问我他该怎么办？我说：“听着，伙计，你不该问我那个。那应该是你的决定。”
He asked you?
他问了你？
Yeah. What should he do? I say, you're not supposed to ask me that. And years later, when I'm telling other people this story, they say, now you made a mistake. You should have told him what to do. But I'm saying, no, that's not my place. He knows what to do. I didn't--
是的，他问我该怎么办。我说：“你不该问我那个。”多年后，当我向其他人讲述这个故事时，他们说：“你错了。你当时应该告诉他该怎么做。”但我说：“不，那不是我的位置。他知道该做什么。我不知道……”
Did you think you made a mistake?
你觉得你犯错了吗？
No. No not to this day I didn't believe I made a mistake. I mean, if you have the guts to take somebody's life, at least have the guts to take the penalty. But still, he was so young that he was still trying to, like, say, yo, I'm going to beat this.
没有。直到今天我也不认为我犯了错。我的意思是，如果你有胆量夺走某人的生命，至少得有胆量承担惩罚。但即便如此，他当时还是太年轻，还在试图说：“哟，我会挺过这一关的。”
Norman turned down the plea bargain, and a second trial was set. But Collin was optimistic about his chances, as was his lawyer, Bruce Richenstrick.
诺曼拒绝了认罪辩诉协议，第二场审判排上了日程。但科林对自己的胜算很乐观，他的律师布鲁斯·里肯斯特里克也一样。
I remember opening to the jury and telling them that this case was a one witness case and that the one witness they were going to hear was a liar-- an unmitigated, pathological liar.
我记得向陪审团作开庭陈述时，我告诉他们，这是一起单证人案件，而他们将听到的那名证人是个骗子——一个彻头彻尾的病态撒谎者。
In this kind of story, this is usually where you hear that Collin was represented by a drunk who fell asleep at his trial, or an overworked and inexperienced public defender, or someone who never handled a murder trial before. That wasn't the case here. Bruce Richenstrick, Collin's lawyer in both his first and second trial, was a former homicide DA with years of experience. He says he never thought the case would get very far because, as a former prosecutor, he knew the prosecution's evidence was lousy.
在这一类故事里，你通常会听说科林是由一个在庭审中睡觉的酒鬼律师代表的，或者是一个过度劳累且缺乏经验的公设辩护人，又或者是一个从没处理过谋杀案的人。这里的情况并非如此。布鲁斯·里肯斯特里克，科林两次审判的律师，是一位拥有多年经验的前凶杀案检察官。他说他从没想过这个案子会走得很远，因为作为一名前检察官，他知道检方的证据非常拙劣。
In fact, there wasn't any evidence tying Collin to the crime except Thomas Charlemagne, that 14-year-old kid who told the cops he saw everything and later picked Collin out of a mug book. But his story kept changing. First, he said that Mario was shot in a drive-by shooting. Later, he said the car stopped and the shooter got out. First he said there was two people in the car. Later, it was four. And most importantly, he initially told the cops that Collin fired the gun that killed Mario. But then at trial, he surprised everyone and said Collin was just the driver. Norman did the shooting.
事实上，除了托马斯·查理曼——那个告诉警察他看到了一切、后来在照片册中指认科林的 14 岁孩子外，没有任何证据将科林与犯罪联系起来。但他故事一直在变。起初，他说马里奥是在行驶的车辆中被射杀的。后来，他说车停下了，射手走了出来。起初他说车里有两个人，后来变成了四个。最重要的是，他最初告诉警察是科林开了枪杀害了马里奥。但在庭审中，他让所有人震惊，说科林只是司机，是诺曼开的枪。
All this lying was good news for Bruce Richenstrick, Collin's defense attorney. Here he reads from his cross-examination of Thomas Charlemagne at the trial.
所有这些谎言对科林的辩护律师布鲁斯·里肯斯特里克来说是个好消息。他在此朗读了他在审判中交叉询问托马斯·查理曼的记录。
And I say to him, "Mr. Charlemagne, when you first spoke to Detective Wasser in this case, did you tell him that Collin Warner was the driver of this car? Answer, yes. And did you also tell him that the driver of the car was the very same person who shot Mario Hamilton? Answer, yes. So when you first spoke to Detective Wasser and you told him that Collin Warner shot Mario Hamilton, that wasn't true, was it? Answer, no. Question, and when you went before a grand jury in reference to this case, you knew in your mind, did you not, that Collin Warner never shot Mario Hamilton. Is that right? Answer, yes. Question, and then you proceeded to tell the grand jury in April of 1980 that Collin Warner shot Mario Hamilton. Answer, yes. Question, so you lied to the grand jury? Answer, yes."
我说：“查理曼先生，当您第一次向本案的瓦瑟警探陈述时，您是否告诉他科林·华纳是车上的司机？回答：是的。而且您是否还告诉他，车上的司机正是射杀马里奥·汉密尔顿的那个人？回答：是的。所以当您第一次见到瓦瑟警探并告诉他科林·华纳射杀了马里奥·汉密尔顿时，那不是真的，对吧？回答：不是。问题：当您就此案出庭大陪审团时，您心中清楚，科林·华纳从未射杀马里奥·汉密尔顿，对吗？回答：是的。问题：那么您在 1980 年 4 月却继续告诉大陪审团是科林·华纳射杀了马里奥·汉密尔顿？回答：是的。问题：所以您对大陪审团撒谎了？回答：是的。”
I mean, from reading this transcript, it looks like this is an open and shut, like Collin's going to walk out the door.
我的意思是，读这份笔录看起来这是一场完全可以胜诉的官司，科林好像马上就能走出大门。
Yeah. The best thing that could possibly happen for any defendant is to have the only witness agree in front of a jury that he lied.
是的，对于任何被告来说，最有利的事情就是让唯一的证人在陪审团面前承认自己撒谎。
One thing I remember about Thomas's testimony was that he never looked me in my eye.
关于托马斯的证词，我记得的一件事是他从不看我的眼睛。
Again, Collin Warner.
再次回到科林·华纳。
Even when he pointed me out in court, he said-- he bent his head down and pointed his finger there. And the judge even had to say, listen, you look-- you sure he's the right guy? And he just glanced at me and, you know, said, yes, Collin Warner is right there. Because he knew he was lying. He know. He knew. Everybody knew. When he was giving his testimony, people were laughing. Even the court officers had bets that I was going to win. I was going to win my case.
即使在法庭上指认我时，他也只是低下头，指着那里。法官甚至不得不说：“听着，你看看……你确定他是对的人吗？”他只是瞥了我一眼，说：“是的，科林·华纳就在那儿。”因为他知道他在撒谎。他知道。他知道。大家都知道。当他作证时，人们都在笑。甚至法警都打赌我会赢。我会赢下官司。
How did you know that?
你是怎么知道的？
No, they told us, you know, because they see us coming to court every day. You know what I'm saying? And sometimes they talk to us and some would say, listen, man. You have a good shot, man. You know what I'm saying? That guy's lying.
不，他们告诉我们的，因为他们看到我们每天都来法庭。你明白我的意思吗？有时他们会和我们交谈，有些人会说：“听着，伙计，你有很大的胜算，伙计。你明白吗？那家伙在撒谎。”
The trial lasted less than a week, and according to Collin, the jury deliberated just three hours.
审判持续不到一周，据科林说，陪审团只商议了三个小时。
The day of the verdict, I think the verdict came in at 12 o'clock. They read my verdict first. You know, Collin Warner, you know, guilty of murder in the second degree. And Norman Simmonds, guilty of murder in the second degree.
判决那天，我想是 12 点宣判的。他们先宣读了我的判决。你知道，“科林·华纳，二级谋杀罪名成立。诺曼·西蒙兹，二级谋杀罪名成立。”
And after that, like it hit 12 o'clock. And there are some bells downtown Brooklyn. They started to ring, so the whole courtroom was quiet because you can't hear when the judge speaks. So everybody was quiet until the bells struck 12 times. And here, I'm telling you, when that foreperson said guilty, it's like my whole life flashed in front of my face. You know, and my knees just got weak-- you know what I'm saying-- because I sat down in the chair because I couldn't believe it. Even to this day, I'm saying, like, how could you say guilty listening to the evidence?
那之后，刚好 12 点。布鲁克林市中心的钟声响了，整个法庭非常安静，因为你听不到法官说话。所以每个人都很安静，直到钟声响了 12 下。我告诉你，当陪审团领班说“有罪”时，就像我整个人生在我面前闪回一样。我的膝盖发软——你懂我的意思吗——我瘫坐在椅子上，因为我简直无法相信。即使到了今天，我还在想，只听这些证据怎么就能定罪？
If this doesn't seem to make much sense, remember that Collin and Norman were on trial together, and the police insisted Collin was involved. So even though Thomas's testimony didn't really add up, to the jury, Collin must have had something to do with it. And Bruce Richenstrick has another theory. He thinks the guilty verdict had more to do with what was going on outside the courtroom than in. The crime rate was soaring, and people were reacting in some pretty extreme ways.
如果这看起来没什么道理，请记住科林和诺曼是一起受审的，而警方坚持认为科林参与其中。所以即使托马斯的证词根本站不住脚，对陪审团来说，科林肯定也参与了。布鲁斯·里肯斯特里克有另一个理论。他认为有罪判决更多是受法庭外氛围的影响，而非庭内。当时的犯罪率正在飙升，人们的反应非常极端。
If you recall, within months of this particular case, the Avenue X murder of Willie Turks had taken place, where a mob beat a black transit worker to death. Within a year or two of that case, we had Bernhard Goetz shooting four blacks on a subway train and ending up getting a year in jail for possession of a weapon. There is-- there was a pervasive, overriding fear in the city, I believe, at that time. And I think that, to some degree, that might have had something to do with Collin Warner's conviction, that he was at that time a black man accused of murder. Well, that's all the jury needed.
如果你还记得，就在这个案子发生的几个月内，发生了威利·特克斯在 X 大道被谋杀的事件，一群暴徒活活打死了一名黑人运输工人。在那之后的一两年里，又发生了伯恩哈德·格茨在地铁上枪击四名黑人，结果仅因非法持枪获刑一年的事件。我相信当时城市里有一种普遍、压倒性的恐惧。我认为在某种程度上，这可能与科林·华纳被定罪有关，因为当时他是一个被控谋杀的黑人。好吧，这就是陪审团所需要的。
The judge perhaps needed a little more. Judge Albert Murray, who presided over Collin's trial, was one of the few African American judges in New York. During sentencing, he gave a sort of tortured apologetic speech to the courtroom. He said, quote, "With all my training, or at least what I've gone through, when it comes to a point like this, I realize how inadequate or how much I rely upon not pure guess, but upon hope, and how mysterious it is and how hard it is to understand why this situation exists right now. The system that we have, we put in process. Is it perfect? Is this verdict true? I don't pretend to know. I don't have the capacity to actually know." End quote. Bruce Richenstrick says he'd never heard anything like it.
法官需要的可能更多。主持科林庭审的艾伯特·默里法官是纽约为数不多的非裔美国法官之一。在量刑时，他向法庭发表了一种近乎折磨般的道歉演讲。他说，引用：“凭我所有的培训，或者说我经历的一切，当事情到了这个地步，我意识到我是多么的无能，或者说我依赖的不是纯粹的猜测，而是希望，这是多么神秘，多么难以理解为什么这种情况现在存在。我们建立的系统，我们执行它。它是完美的吗？这个判决是真的吗？我并不假装知道。我没有能力真正知道。”引用结束。布鲁斯·里肯斯特里克说他从未听过这样的发言。
I think that Judge Murray was voicing what the overriding feeling was in the courtroom. How did the jury reach that verdict? And there wasn't even anything in the courtroom-- in an atmosphere in the courtroom-- to give us any kind of indication that this result was going to be reached. It was completely a surprise. It was a surprise to me. It was a surprise to Collin Warner. And by the judge's words, which I hadn't heard in a long time, I think it was probably a surprise to him.
我认为默里法官表达了法庭上压倒性的感受。陪审团是怎么得出那个判决的？法庭上甚至没有任何氛围表明会得出这样的结果。这完全是个惊喜。对我来说是个意外。对科林·华纳来说是个意外。而从法官的话来看，这对我来说很久没听过了，我想这对他来说可能也是个意外。
Judge Murray had no choice but to sentence Collin. He gave him the minimum allowed by law, 15 years to life.
默里法官别无选择，只能判处科林刑罚。他给了法律允许的最低刑期：15 年至终身监禁。
The sentence didn't hit me until I got to the reception center for the Department of Corrections. They deloused me. Had me-- had about 50 of us in a shower area, stripped butt naked, you know, sprayed delousing on our arms, you know, on our testicles and then bending over and spraying it in our anus and all that. You know what I mean?
直到我被送到惩教署的接待中心，判刑的感觉才真正击中我。他们给我除虱子。大约 50 个人在淋浴区，被脱得一丝不挂，你知道，在我们的手臂、睾丸上喷除虱剂，然后弯下腰在肛门处喷射，诸如此类。你懂我的意思吗？
And it was so degrading. You know what I mean? And then I started to cry, you know what I mean, because I'm saying, like, you can't do nothing about it. You're here at these people's mercy. You know what I mean? And they lock you into a cell where there's a lot of prisoners. It's just like tiers upon tiers of prisoners, and everybody is shouting. And it's like-- it's like a mad house, you know? And I'm just trying to like-- you know, where the hell-- how did I get here? You know what I'm saying? It's like I was transported to another planet.
那真是太屈辱了。你知道吗？然后我开始哭，因为我想，你对此无能为力。你在这里任由这些人摆布。你知道吗？然后他们把你关进一个关满囚犯的牢房里。就像一层又一层的囚犯，每个人都在尖叫。这就像——这就像个疯人院，你知道吗？我只是在想——到底……我怎么会来到这里？你明白我的意思吗？就像我被传送到了另一个星球。
This is where Carl King comes in, the guy you heard at the very beginning of the show. He was one of Collin Warner's oldest friends. They grew up together in a village in Trinidad, got even closer when they moved to Brooklyn. Carl took up Collin's case, partly because they were friends, and partly because he just couldn't help himself. He's the kind of guy who can devote his life to a cause, and Collin became his cause.
这就是卡尔·金出场的地方，也就是节目开头你听到的那个人。他是科林·华纳最好的朋友之一。他们在特立尼达的一个村庄一起长大，搬到布鲁克林后关系更加亲密。卡尔接手了科林的案子，部分因为他们是朋友，部分因为他自己根本控制不住。他是那种可以为事业奉献一生的人，而科林成了他的事业。
He visited Collin regularly in jail, went to his court appearances. Here's Carl.
他定期去监狱探望科林，参加他的庭审。卡尔在这里。
It was a bad feeling. Talking about it now, you know, my pulse is just racing because I tell myself that, you know, it could have been me. And I felt like it's me because it was actually to see like there's a big whale come and just swallow you up, and nobody can just dig in that whale's stomach. It was-- I felt hopeless at that time.
那感觉很糟糕。现在谈论它，你知道，我的脉搏在加速，因为我告诉自己，那个人可能是我。我感觉就像是我自己，因为这就好比看到一头巨大的鲸鱼过来把你吞下，没人能潜进那头鲸鱼的胃里。那时我感到绝望。
Carl and Collin had only just finished high school. Their families had no money. They didn't know any lawyers, and they weren't politically connected. So Carl made do, and he used the connections that he had.
卡尔和科林刚高中毕业。他们的家庭没有钱。他们不认识任何律师，也没有政治关系。所以卡尔将就着办，利用他所能利用的一切关系。
Even if you come pick up some garbage, I would really talk to you and tell you, listen, I have a friend in jail, and he's innocent. Actually, everybody I encountered, Collin's case was always the issue.
即使你只是来倒垃圾的，我也会真的和你交谈，告诉你：“听着，我有个朋友在监狱里，他是无辜的。”事实上，我遇到的每个人，科林的案子总是话题。
Carl and Collin strategized about appeals. Carl raised money on the outside. Collin learned to use the prison law library. He put together the first appeal himself. It was denied. For the second appeal, Carl found a lawyer in the yellow pages-- also denied. The next was a real estate lawyer Carl met while he was closing on his house-- denied. And then they managed to get one of the most famous defense lawyers in the country, William Kunstler, defender of the Chicago Seven, Lenny Bruce, Martin Luther King. That appeal failed as well.
卡尔和科林制定了上诉策略。卡尔在外面筹集资金，科林学会了使用监狱法律图书馆。他自己完成了第一次上诉，被驳回了。第二次上诉，卡尔从黄页上找了一位律师——也被驳回了。接下来是一位卡尔在卖房子结算时认识的房地产律师——驳回。然后他们设法请到了全美最著名的辩护律师之一，威廉·康斯特勒，芝加哥七人案、列尼·布鲁斯、马丁·路德·金的辩护人。那次上诉也失败了。
As the years passed, Collin wasn't doing well in jail. He kept getting in fights, mostly with the guards. He spent four of his first 10 years in prison in the box-- solitary confinement. It was the fact that he shouldn't have been there at all, he says, that made him such a nightmare inmate.
随着岁月流逝，科林在监狱里过得并不好。他不断惹事打架，主要是和警卫。他入狱后的头 10 年里有 4 年是在禁闭室度过的。他说，正是因为他根本不该出现在那儿，才让他成了一个令警卫头疼的囚犯。
Because I'm saying, like, the rules don't apply to me then because I'm innocent. But that wasn't the case, you know? In their eyes, I was guilty.
因为我心想，如果我是无辜的，那么这些规矩就不适用。但事实并非如此，你知道吗？在他们眼里，我有罪。
Eventually, Collin stopped rebelling. He enrolled in classes and work programs. Carl would visit often, bringing food, new clothes. One day he brought a friend with him. She and Collin hit it off and eventually got married.
最终，科林不再反抗。他参加了课程和工作项目。卡尔经常探望他，带去食物和新衣服。有一天，他带了一个朋友来。她和科林一见钟情，最终结婚了。
By 1993, Collin had been in prison for over a dozen years, and he and Carl took stock. All their appeals had failed. Maybe their strategy was wrong. They'd focused on legal technicalities at the trial. Had the rules of evidence been followed properly? Was there misconduct by the prosecution? That sort of thing. Carl wanted to take a new approach. He wanted to reinvestigate the crime, come up with new evidence and witnesses, do the detective work the detectives never did.
到了 1993 年，科林已经在狱中呆了十多年了，他和卡尔评估了局势。他们所有的上诉都失败了。也许他们的策略错了。他们专注于审判中的法律技术细节。证据规则是否被正确遵循？检方是否有不当行为？这类事情。卡尔想采取一种新方法。他想重新调查这起犯罪，寻找新的证据和证人，做那些侦探从未做过的调查工作。
At that point, money was exhausted. And we knew that we have to try to clear Collin's name, not based on legal, technical stuff, but actually what happened on that day. We were going to try to see how we can go about proving his innocence.
那时，钱已经花光了。我们知道我们必须试着洗清科林的名字，不是基于法律上的技术问题，而是基于那天实际发生了什么。我们打算看看如何证明他的清白。
But how do you go about investigating a crime over a decade after it's been committed? Carl had no experience. Up till then, he'd done a little construction, drove a cab. But he saw an opportunity when he bumped into his brother-in-law one day with a stack of court documents in his hands. His brother-in-law was working as a process server, hand-delivering legal papers, like eviction notices and subpoenas, and filing them at court. Carl thought a job like that would be a good way to learn how the system works and to meet attorneys who might help with the case, so he got his license to start serving papers. He learned how to track people down, how to order court files, and how to read legal motions. He took all the legal papers back from Collin's lawyer.
但如何在犯罪发生十多年后去调查呢？卡尔没有任何经验。在那之前，他做过一点建筑工作，开过出租车。但他有一天撞见他姐夫手里拿着一摞法庭文件时，看到了一线机会。他姐夫是一名法律送达员，负责亲手递送法律文件，比如驱逐通知和传票，并将其归档到法院。卡尔认为这种工作是了解系统如何运作以及结识可能帮助案子的律师的好方法，于是他拿到了执照开始送文件。他学会了如何追踪人，如何订购法庭卷宗，以及如何阅读法律动议。他从科林的律师那里收回了所有法律文件。
And I started familiarizing with the reports as to the police reports, the grand jury minutes, the trial transcripts, and also the motions, the pretrial motions, started familiarizing with it. Then my clients were attorneys. I started asking them questions, you know?
我开始熟悉关于警方报告、大陪审团会议纪要、庭审记录，还有动议、预审动议等报告，开始熟悉这些。然后我的客户是律师。我开始问他们问题，你知道吗？
Some of the attorneys seemed sympathetic, but none were ready to jump in and help. Then one day, Carl was standing in front of a downtown Brooklyn courthouse trying to drum up some work, handing out business cards to anyone in a suit holding a briefcase. And he gave one to a lawyer named William Robedee. Robedee had recently left the DA's office and was starting his own private practice, mainly housing and divorce court. He needed help, so a few days later he called, and Carl arranged to stop by his office.
有些律师看起来很同情，但没有一个人愿意跳出来帮忙。有一天，卡尔站在布鲁克林市中心的法院前，试图拉点活儿干，给每一个提着公文包穿西装的人发名片。他给了一位名叫威廉·罗贝迪的律师。罗贝迪刚离开地方检察官办公室，开始经营自己的私人业务，主要负责住房和离婚法庭。他需要帮助，所以几天后他打了电话，卡尔安排去他的办公室。
He introduced himself to be William Robedee. And there was a lady sitting at the side of the desk, happened to be his wife. After a while, I saw a guy walk by in a towel, so I was thinking it's strange. Well, that happened to be his roommate. They were sharing.
他介绍自己是威廉·罗贝迪。旁边桌子旁坐着一位女士，恰好是他的妻子。过了一会儿，我看到一个穿着浴巾的家伙走过，我觉得很奇怪。原来那是他的室友。他们住在一起。
Well, at the time, the office was my apartment on 77th Street in Brooklyn.
当时办公室就是我在布鲁克林第 77 街的公寓。
This is William Robedee.
这是威廉·罗贝迪。
So I mean there was two bedrooms in the back, and then there was, like, a living room, and then the room that I used as an office, and the kitchen. And I'd say the first few times he came to pick up work from me-- papers that needed to be served-- we had a few conversations, and we kind of hit it off as friends fairly fast.
所以我的意思是后面有两个卧室，然后有一个起居室，然后是我用作办公室的房间，还有厨房。我想他最初几次来我这里拿活儿干——那些需要送达的文件——我们有过几次交谈，我们作为朋友很快就合得来了。
We started working together. Immediately after, I was telling him, Saturday I'm going upstate to visit my friend. And I told him the story as to how my friend is in jail for something he did not do, and he was pretty much touched. And then the lady who always sits at his side, she came closer to hear the story. And we sat there for, like, about two, three hours that day when I first tell them about the story. So one day, he told me shortly after, why don't I bring, you know, some materials over?
我们开始一起工作。紧接着，我告诉他：“周六我要去上州看我的朋友。”我告诉他我朋友因为没做过的事入狱的故事，他被打动了。一直坐在他身边的女士也凑近听这个故事。那天我第一次讲这个故事时，我们坐了大概两三个小时。所以不久后的一天，他告诉我不妨带些材料过来。
He brought it over in a box. It was about a foot and a half-- good 18 inches thick-- of paper. He had the trial transcripts, police paperwork, discovery materials that would have been in possession of Collin's defense attorney at the time of the trial in 1982. And myself and Shirley sat up probably till 3 o'clock in the morning that night just passing papers back and forth around the table and going through about four pots of coffee. And I would think before we went to bed that night, I was convinced he didn't do it.
他用一个盒子装了过来。大约有一英尺半——足足 18 英寸厚——的纸张。里面有审判记录、警方文件、1982 年审判时科林的辩护律师可能持有的发现材料。我和雪莉那天晚上大概一直坐到凌晨 3 点，就在桌子两边传阅文件，喝了大概四壶咖啡。我想在那晚睡觉前，我已经确信他没干那事。
I mean, there was no murder weapon recovered. There were no forensics. And the bullet had a downward trajectory in their own autopsy report from 20 years ago. And the theory of the case was that it was a drive by shooting, which, unless you are sitting on top of a tank, it would be physically impossible for the murder to have happened the way that the witnesses testified to it at the trial.
我的意思是，没有找回凶器。没有任何法医证据。在 20 年前的尸检报告中，子弹轨迹是向下的。而案件的理论是这是一起驾车扫射，除非你是坐在坦克顶上，否则谋杀案按证人在庭审中作证的方式发生，在物理上是不可能的。
Carl and Robedee worked out a barter arrangement. Carl would deliver papers in exchange for Robedee's help with Collin's case. It was 1999. Collin had been in jail for almost 20 years, which might seem odd considering that he had a sentence of 15 years to life. But when you come up before the parole board, part of what they're looking for is that you accept responsibility for your crime and show remorse. But for Collin, accepting responsibility would have meant lying.
卡尔和罗贝迪达成了以物易物的安排。卡尔帮忙送达法律文件，换取罗贝迪在科林案子上的帮助。那是 1999 年。科林已经在监狱里关了近 20 年了，考虑到他被判了 15 年到终身监禁，这看起来有点奇怪。但当你出现在假释委员会面前时，他们寻找的一部分是你承认犯罪并表现出悔意。但对科林来说，承认责任意味着撒谎。
Reading the minutes of his parole board hearing, you see the awful trap he's in. At one point in the transcript, Collin says he's innocent, but Commissioner Rafelli, who's conducting the meeting, responds like this.
阅读他的假释委员会听证会纪要，你会看到他身陷的可怕陷阱。在笔录的某处，科林说他是无辜的，但负责主持会议的拉菲利委员却这样回应。
Quote, "As far as we're concerned, the parole board, you are guilty of murder. The parole board does not determine issues of guilt or innocence. If you want to continue to fight that issue, by all means, get yourself an attorney and appeal it. Take it to the Court of Appeals. Take it to the US Supreme Court, wherever you will. But until a court of higher jurisdiction tells us you are innocent, as far as we're concerned, you're guilty, and that's all there is to it. So I want you to be aware that your protestations of innocence, as far as we're concerned, fall on deaf ears." Unquote.
引用：“就我们假释委员会而言，你犯有谋杀罪。假释委员会不裁定有罪或无罪的问题。如果你想继续纠缠那个问题，务必请个律师去上诉。把它带到上诉法院。带到美国最高法院，随你便。但直到更高管辖权的法院告诉我们你是无辜的，否则就我们而言，你有罪，事情就是这样。所以我希望你意识到，你的清白抗议在我们看来是对牛弹琴。”引用结束。
After arguing his case for a couple of pages, Collin finally gives up, and he says, "Whatever I tell you, you're not going to believe me anyway." Needless to say, his parole was denied. And it was denied every time he went up for parole. Here's the catch. If he lied and said he committed the crime, he would have been released long ago.
在辩论了几页之后，科林终于放弃了，他说：“无论我告诉你什么，反正你也不会相信我。”不用说，他的假释申请被拒绝了。而且每次他去申请假释都被拒绝。关键就在这儿。如果他撒谎说他犯了罪，他早就可以获释了。
Coming up, getting a murderer to admit to murder and getting him to help the helpless. Our story continues in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，让一个杀人犯承认谋杀并帮助无助的人。我们的故事将在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续后在一分钟内继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today we're spending our entire program on the story of Carl King and how he managed to right a 20-year wrong against some pretty amazing odds. Today's show was first broadcast back in 2005. Again, here's reporter Anya Bourg.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们把整个节目都用在讲述卡尔·金的故事，讲述他如何在面对相当惊人的困难时成功纠正了一个 20 年的错误。今天的节目最早是在 2005 年播出的。再次有请记者安雅·布尔格。
Carl King and attorney William Robedee took to meeting regularly. They'd gather in Robedee's apartment and discuss strategy. They both agreed they had to go back and uncover what actually happened on the day of the murder, so they poured over the police notes and paperwork from the trial. There were names that kept coming up-- Mario, the victim, his brother, Martell, the real shooter, Norman, and the main eyewitness, Thomas Charlemagne. They thought this group was a good place to start. Here's Robedee.
卡尔·金和律师威廉·罗贝迪开始定期会面。他们会在罗贝迪的公寓里聚会，讨论策略。他们都认为必须回去查明谋杀当天到底发生了什么，于是他们仔细研究了警方记录和庭审文件。有几个名字不断出现——受害者马里奥，他的兄弟马特尔，真正的射手诺曼，以及主要目击者托马斯·查理曼。他们认为从这群人开始是个好主意。罗贝迪说：
I knew that they knew something. I mean, you know, there's Mario, Martell, Norman, Carlton, and all these guys were kind of bonded together in the way that kind of only teenage boys end up bonded together. I mean, the whole story just had that kind of flavor to it where you just knew that if there was a truth to this thing, then one of these kids knew it.
我知道他们知道些什么。我的意思是，有马里奥、马特尔、诺曼、卡尔顿，这些家伙以一种只有十几岁男孩才会有的方式紧密联系在一起。整个故事就是有那种味道，让你知道如果这件事有真相，那么其中一个孩子肯定知道。
So they decided to start with the most obvious suspect, the real shooter, Norman Simmonds, the guy Collin had been tried and convicted with. In a weird twist, because he was a minor and a model inmate, he'd only served nine years in prison, and he proved surprisingly easy for Robedee to track down.
所以他们决定从最明显的嫌疑人开始——真正的射手诺曼·西蒙兹，那个和科林一起被审判并定罪的人。在一个奇怪的转折中，因为他当时未成年且表现良好，他只在监狱里呆了九年，罗贝迪发现要找到他意外地简单。
To be honest with you, I took a stab in the dark that an address that we found on the internet was him and sent him a letter. Believe it or not, that worked. He called.
老实说，我在网上找到一个地址，抱着试试看的心态给他寄了封信。信不信由你，真的管用了。他打来了电话。
They arranged for Norman come over the next day to give a deposition. So the following afternoon, they were there waiting-- a court reporter at the kitchen table, Robedee's wife, Shirley, lying in the living room floor arranging the papers, and Robedee, preparing the questions.
他们安排诺曼第二天过来录口供。所以第二天下午，他们在那里等着——餐桌上坐着法庭速记员，罗贝迪的妻子雪莉躺在客厅地板上整理文件，罗贝迪准备问题。
We had an appointment for him at 3 o'clock. The doorbell rang at 2:00. And I looked outside, and it was, at that time, a brand new S550 Mercedes sedan double parked in front of my house. And I said, I think that might be Norman. And he was coming up around the stairs, shouting up something to the effect of, yo, where's the lawyer?
我们预约他 3 点到。结果 2 点门铃就响了。我向外看去，那是一辆当时全新的 S550 梅赛德斯轿车，双排停在我的屋子前面。我说：“我想那可能是诺曼。”他绕着楼梯走上来，大喊大叫，大概意思是：“哟，律师在哪里？”
He was, like, you know, dressed like kind of, you know, a pop star.
他穿得有点像……流行歌星。
Shirley Robedee.
雪莉·罗贝迪。
You know, the Versace suit and laid out and perfect hair and, you know, with the hand inside the jacket pocket.
你知道，范思哲西装，搭配得完美，发型完美，手还插在夹克口袋里。
Yeah I believe, you know-- and I kind of saw enough close enough evidence of that every time he's moved his jacket-- that he was sitting in my living room well armed.
是的，我相信，我每次他移动夹克时都能看到足够近的证据，证明他坐在我的客厅里可是全副武装。
So Robedee, his wife, Shirley, and a now slightly freaked out court reporter all sat down and listened as Norman Simmonds walked them through what happened on the day of Mario's shooting. Since you can't be tried for the same crime twice, he told them the story candidly-- at times, too candidly.
所以罗贝迪、他的妻子雪莉，以及一个现在有点被吓坏了的速记员都坐下来听诺曼·西蒙兹讲述马里奥中枪那天发生了什么。因为你不能因同一罪行被审判两次，他坦诚地告诉了他们故事——有时过于坦诚了。
He actually demonstrated on me, physically. He asked me to stand up and play Mario Hamilton while he came up behind me with his finger and his thumb and showed me exactly how he shot him. Norman basically used me as his demonstration dummy and where he put his finger on my neck is exactly where that bullet went in on that autopsy report, which was utterly consistent, as opposed to the story that was told at the trial, which was utterly inconsistent.
他实际上在我的身上做现场演示。他让我站起来扮演马里奥·汉密尔顿，他走到我身后，用食指和拇指比划着演示他到底是如何射杀马里奥的。诺曼基本上把我当成了他的演示模特，他把手指放在我脖子上的位置正是那份尸检报告中子弹射入的位置，这与他在庭审中讲述的、完全矛盾的故事形成了鲜明对比，这完全吻合。
What Norman had given us was the actual story of how the murder actually happened. He stated to us that, to make a long story short, that himself and a person named Mossep-- who we later learned was named Dayton Morgan-- were walking basically behind Erasmus Hall High School, which is on Flatbush Avenue. And they spotted Mario Hamilton, and they walked up behind Mario Hamilton. Norman took a pistol from his waistband and basically almost at kind of a point blank range, shot Mario through the top of his neck. That sequence of events, we had never actually heard before.
诺曼告诉我们的是谋杀实际发生过程的真实故事。长话短说，他告诉我们，他和一个人名叫莫塞普的——我们后来知道叫代顿·摩根——当时基本上走在位于弗拉特布什大道的伊拉斯谟霍尔高中后面。他们发现了马里奥·汉密尔顿，并走到马里奥身后。诺曼从腰带里掏出一把手枪，基本上是在近距离射击马里奥的脖子顶部。那个事件序列，我们以前从未听说过。
There was no car. There was no driver. And most importantly, there was no Collin Warner. Norman said he'd killed Mario in revenge for the death of a friend the week before, just like the neighborhood kids told the cops at the time. By the end of the deposition, Robedee had only one question left.
根本没有车。没有司机。最重要的是，没有科林·华纳。诺曼说他是为了给前一周死去的兄弟报仇才杀了马里奥，正如当时社区的孩子们告诉警察的那样。在口供结束时，罗贝迪只剩最后一个问题。
So after we had stopped, I said to him again, you know, why, why did you let this happen? Why did it go on so long? And his answer to that question began with, I was only 15. And he got very, very emotional. He was physically crying. The only way I can explain it, it was like a dam bursting with Norman. It all just kind of rushed out of him. I believe I hugged him.
所以我们停下后，我又问他：“你为什么，你为什么要让这种事发生？为什么拖了这么久？”他回答那个问题时开口说：“我当时才 15 岁。”他变得非常、非常激动。他真的在哭。我能解释的唯一方式就是，这就像诺曼体内的大坝决堤了。一切都倾泻而出。我想我拥抱了他。
The most important thing Carl and Robedee got from Norman wasn't his confession. That alone isn't enough to vacate a conviction. What Norman gave them was the names of all the people who'd seen him commit the crime, real eyewitnesses, people who were within feet when he fired the gun, but who'd never testified in court. There were two of them.
卡尔和罗贝迪从诺曼那里得到的最重要的东西不是他的供词。单凭这个不足以推翻定罪。诺曼给他们的是所有看到他犯罪的人的名字——真正的目击者，那些他在开枪时就在几英尺内的人，但他们从未在法庭上作证。一共有两个。
Now Carl had to find them, to be a detective. One of the eyewitnesses had gone into the Marines, and Carl tracked him down through a guy in the neighborhood. The other was Dayton Morgan, also known as Mossep. He wasn't as easy to locate. Carl started with a process server trick. He ran a DMV search and found an address Mossep had given the court when he appeared for a traffic violation. The only problem was when Carl went up to the Bronx neighborhood to find the address, it didn't exist.
现在卡尔必须找到他们，去当侦探。其中一名目击者已经加入了海军陆战队，卡尔通过社区里的一个人追踪到了他。另一个是代顿·摩根，也叫莫塞普。他没那么容易定位。卡尔开始使用送达员的把戏。他跑了一趟车管所搜索，找到了莫塞普因违反交通规则出庭时给法院的地址。唯一的问题是当卡尔去布朗克斯那个社区寻找地址时，那个地址根本不存在。
The street sense came in there. I thought, if I gave you an address, and I said to you, I live at 915, and there's no 915 on this block, that means that I know this block that well to give you a wrong, you know, number. I knew at that time he had to know that block.
街头智慧在那儿派上了用场。我想，如果我给你一个地址，说我住在 915 号，但那个街区根本没有 915 号，这意味着我非常了解这个街区，以至于能给你一个错误的号码。我知道当时他肯定很了解那个街区。
Carl started casing the neighborhood. He talked to people at the deli, the guy selling odds and ends in the street, neighborhood folks. He tried not to look out of place, but sometimes he took it a little far.
卡尔开始踩点那个社区。他和熟食店的人、在街上卖零碎东西的人、社区居民交谈。他尽量让自己看起来不那么显眼，但有时他做得有点过头了。
One day I was dressed up in a mechanic's suit.
有一天我穿着修理工的制服。
Wait. Wait. Wait. You're going up there and hanging around the neighborhood, figuring out where he is. Are you going in a costume?
等等，等等。你去那儿在社区里转悠，想弄清楚他在哪儿。你是穿了戏服吗？
Well, a mechanic's suit because I can't really look like I'm just laying around in a strange neighborhood, so I mean people won't really look at you that direct if, you know, you're a tradesman or worker. So I had on this mechanic's suit, and my boots are all dirty. So I was, like, parked, like, two cars away. So I saw him coming across the street to approach the building, and I just wanted to verify the apartment and if he's staying in that building.
嗯，修理工制服，因为我不希望看起来像在一个陌生的社区游荡，人们不会太在意如果你是个手艺人或工人。我穿着这身修理工制服，靴子很脏。我把车停在离那两辆车远的地方。我看到他穿过街道走向那栋楼，我只想确认一下房间，看看他是不是真的住在那里。
So he's going to open the door-- open it like that-- so I just slide in. So I'm walking, like, ahead of him, and he's walking behind. And I'm whistling. So I'm walking up the steps. So it's four floors in that building. So I'm saying, I hope it's not the last floor that he's going to because I don't know who I'll be knocking because I want to see the apartment he's actually staying in. Fortunately, I heard the keys jingling on the third floor, so then I went up to the fourth floor, stood there for a minute, make sure he's inside, and I came back down, come out the building.
所以他要开门了——打开门——我就溜了进去。所以我走在他前面，他在后面走。我在吹口哨。所以我走上台阶。那栋楼有四层。我心想，希望他去的不是最后一层，因为我不知道我会敲哪扇门，我想看看他住的房间。幸运的是，我听到了三楼钥匙响的声音，所以我上了四楼，站了一会儿，确认他在里面，然后就下楼离开了。
Carl says in an investigation, there are all sorts of advantages that someone from the neighborhood has that an outsider doesn't. This seemed especially true in the case of Taheem Allen, one of the teenagers who'd lied to the police and the grand jury in the original investigation. Taheem was kind of a street character, not the type who'd open up to just anyone, and also a guy somebody official would have a hard time finding.
卡尔说，在调查中，当地人有外人没有的各种优势。这在塔希姆·艾伦的案例中显得尤为真实，他是最初调查中向警察和陪审团撒谎的青少年之一。塔希姆是个街头混混，不是那种会对随便谁敞开心扉的人，也是官方人员很难找到的那种人。
But here, Norman Simmonds was a help. After he gave his tearful deposition to Carl and Robedee admitting he was the lone murderer, he told them he knew Taheem, knew where he hung out. So Carl got in Norman's Mercedes S550, the one with the tinted windows, and drove with him to see Taheem at a restaurant in a really tough Brooklyn neighborhood. When they walked in, it was dark, but Norman pointed Taheem out in the corner. Carl introduced himself, and it didn't take much more than that.
但在这里，诺曼·西蒙兹帮了忙。在他向卡尔和罗贝迪提供了充满泪水的供词承认自己是独狼杀手后，他告诉他们他认识塔希姆，知道他常在哪儿晃荡。所以卡尔坐上了诺曼那辆车窗贴膜的 S550 梅赛德斯，开车带他去布鲁克林一个非常混乱的街区的餐馆见塔希姆。当他们走进餐馆时，里面很黑，但诺曼指出了躲在角落里的塔希姆。卡尔做了自我介绍，没费什么劲儿。
The guy was eating some food, actually. And when he heard the name Collin Warner, he just actually rest down his food and tears came to his eyes. And then he said it's always, like, bothered him where, you know, he thinks he's going to get a nervous breakdown, you know, because he kept thinking about whatever happened to this guy. And he said, listen, is there any way I can help you, because I was part of sending an innocent man to jail.
那家伙当时正在吃东西。当他听到“科林·华纳”这个名字时，他放下食物，眼里噙满了泪水。他说这事一直困扰着他，甚至以为自己要精神崩溃了，因为他一直想起那个人的遭遇。他说：“听着，有什么办法能帮到你吗？因为我参与了把一个无辜的人送进监狱。”
By this time, Carl was spending every spare moment working on Collin's case-- between 50 to 100 hours a week, he says. It was coming between him and his friends and family. It's one of the reasons he and his girlfriend, the mother of his kids, split up.
到这个时候，卡尔把每一刻闲暇时间都用在科林的案子上——他说每周工作 50 到 100 小时。这导致他和朋友及家人的关系出现裂痕。这是他和孩子们的母亲也就是他女朋友分手的原因之一。
By 1999, he and Robedee were making progress with the case, but there were still some problems. The key eyewitness, Thomas Charlemagne, the 15-year-old who first chose the photo of Collin at random, had been killed in Haiti years before. And Carl and Robedee knew the witnesses they had weren't enough to convince a judge. Norman was protected by double jeopardy, and Taheem had perjured himself before, so why wouldn't he do it again?
到了 1999 年，他和罗贝迪在案子上取得了进展，但仍有一些问题。关键目击者托马斯·查理曼，那个在 15 岁时随机选中科林照片的孩子，多年前已经在海地被杀。卡尔和罗贝迪知道他们掌握的证人不足以说服法官。诺曼受到“双重危难”保护，而且塔希姆之前做过伪证，谁能保证他这次不会再做呢？
Carl and Robedee knew that to really make their case, they needed someone from the victim's family, someone who'd have no reason to help Collin get out of prison. And it's at this point that a rather surprising person reappears in the story. Martell Hamilton, the brother of the kid who died, the one who ran to the scene of the crime and saw his brother bleeding on the sidewalk. Martell, remember, had been there when Thomas first identified Collin from the mug book, and he'd IDed Collin himself. Taheem knew where he lived, so they mailed a letter.
卡尔和罗贝迪知道，要真正把官司打赢，他们需要受害者家属中的某个人，一个没有理由帮助科林出狱的人。就在这时，一个相当出人意料的人重新出现在故事中。马特尔·汉密尔顿，死者马里奥的兄弟，那个跑向犯罪现场看到弟弟倒在人行道上流血的人。记住，马特尔当时也在场，当托马斯第一次从照片册中指认科林时，他自己也指认了科林。塔希姆知道他住哪儿，所以他们寄了一封信。
It was a hard letter for Martell to read. He'd spent 20 years trying to put the murder out of his mind. The last thing he wanted to do was get back into it with some lawyer he didn't know. He tried to ignore it, but he found he couldn't. So a week later, he came up with a solution of sorts.
这对马特尔来说是一封很难读的信。他花了 20 年时间试图把那起谋杀从脑海中抹去。他最不想做的事情就是与一个他不认识的律师重提往事。他试图忽略它，但发现自己做不到。所以一周后，他想出了一个折中的解决办法。
It was more or less a cop out. I tried to call the attorney Robedee's office. I thought it was an actual office, like most attorneys would have, and I said, I'm going to call him late so he can't say I didn't return the call. So I figured I would get an answering machine, and then I said, OK, I did my part. Now I'm done with it. But came to my surprise, the answering machine came on, and I said, hello, my name is Martell Hamilton. I am the brother of Mario Hamilton, and I received this letter. I'm just only returning your call. Good bye.
这更像是一种逃避。我试着给罗贝迪律师的办公室打电话。我以为那是个真正的办公室，像大多数律师会有的一样，我说：“我晚点打给他，这样他就不能说我没回电了。”所以我以为我会听到答录机，然后我就想，好的，我尽力了，现在没事了。令我吃惊的是，答录机响了，我说：“你好，我叫马特尔·汉密尔顿。我是马里奥·汉密尔顿的兄弟，我收到了这封信。我只是回个电话。再见。”
And then I heard something said, don't hang up! Don't hang up! Don't hang up! And then he said, Mr. Hamilton, you don't know how much this means to me that you called me, you know? And I would like for you to come down and just look at some of the documents and the evidence that we have to show that there's absolutely no way your brother could been killed by my client. I represent Collin Warner. And boy, that was-- that just drew me right back to 1980, April 10 of 1980. And it just felt like somebody just, you know, like stuck a knife in my stomach. And I keep remembering those who said, you know, this guy had nothing to do with it.
然后我听到有人大喊：“别挂断！别挂断！别挂断！”他说：“汉密尔顿先生，你不知道你的电话对我意味着什么，你知道吗？我想请你过来看看我们拥有的一些文件和证据，证明你弟弟绝对不可能被我的客户杀害。我是科林的辩护律师。”天哪，那……那瞬间把我拉回到了 1980 年，1980 年 4 月 10 日。感觉就像有人往我胃里捅了一刀。我一直记得那些说这人与案子无关的人的话。
Martell's family was against him talking to Robedee. They didn't see any reason to get involved. They didn't want to dredge up the past. But Martell hadn't admitted to them his doubts about Collin's guilt, how his friends always told him that Collin had nothing to do with it. Keep in mind, Martell's brother had been his hero. They were incredibly close. They'd shared a room. And he'd seen him bleed to death in front of his eyes. Even today, he carries Mario's picture in his wallet.
马特尔的家人反对他和罗贝迪交谈。他们看不出有任何理由参与进来。他们不想重提过去。但马特尔没向他们承认过他对科林是否有罪的怀疑，也没说他朋友们总是告诉他科林与案子无关。记住，马特尔的弟弟是他的英雄。他们关系极其亲密。他们共用一个房间。他在眼前看着他流血致死。直到今天，他的钱包里还装着马里奥的照片。
So after a couple of days, he went over and looked at all the evidence Carl and Robedee had gathered. By the end, he was convinced enough to give a deposition, to tell them about how Detective Wasser bullied him into saying he'd seen Collin around the neighborhood. But it was really rough. Several times they had to tell the court reporter to stop typing so Martell could take a break, get a tissue. It took hours to get through.
所以两天后，他过去看了卡尔和罗贝迪收集的所有证据。最后，他被说服了，同意录口供，告诉他们瓦瑟警探是如何欺凌他，让他说他在社区里见过科林。但过程真的很艰难。好几次他们不得不告诉速记员停止打字，让马特尔休息一下，递给他纸巾。这花了几个小时才录完。
Why did you feel compelled to speak out for Collin, on Collin's behalf?
为什么你觉得有义务站出来为科林说话，代表科林说话？
I just-- I just couldn't let it rest. And I was trying to let it rest, but that-- because that doubt, you know, I have to do this. I have to do this. Plus for years, I searched for some type of relief from this because if you think I'm emotional now, before 2000, I couldn't mention anything about it. I didn't walk close to Lott Street where he was killed. I couldn't see blood without panicking. And I'm pretty sure that's what it was. It was my doubts within the case.
我只是……我只是没法让这件事就这样过去。我试过让它过去，但那种怀疑，你知道，我必须这样做。我必须这样做。再加上多年来，我一直寻找某种解脱，因为如果你认为我现在很激动，在 2000 年之前，我连提都不能提。我不敢走近他被杀的洛特街。我看到血就会恐慌。我很确定就是那样。那就是我对案件的怀疑。
Martell says he was amazed to learn that Collin didn't hate him. Everyone was just grateful that he came in. And after his deposition, Martell offered to help in any way he could and basically joined what by this point was a small and unlikely team of investigators-- Collin, the inmate, Carl, the process server, Robedee, the housing lawyer working out of his apartment, Taheem, occupation unknown, and now Martell. What's particularly unusual is that 20 years before, they'd been on the opposite sides of the courtroom. Carl was on the side of the accused, and Martell on the side of the victim.
马特尔说，当得知科林并不恨他时，他感到非常惊讶。大家都很感激他能来。在他的口供之后，马特尔主动提出愿意以任何方式提供帮助，并加入了这支当时已经由科林（囚犯）、卡尔（送达员）、罗贝迪（在公寓办公的住房律师）、塔希姆（职业不明）和现在的马特尔组成的意想不到的调查团队。特别不同寻常的是，20 年前，他们分属法庭的两端。卡尔站在被告一方，马特尔站在受害者一方。
It's Martell who finally got Mossep, an eyewitness, to tell the story of what he saw. Martell drove with Carl up to the Bronx to the apartment building Carl had been staking out in his mechanic's uniform. Mossep walked past. Martell followed him inside.
正是马特尔最终让莫塞普（另一名目击者）讲出了他所见的事情。马特尔开车带卡尔前往布朗克斯，去往卡尔穿着修理工服踩点的那栋公寓楼。莫塞普走了过来。马特尔跟着他进了楼。
Then he turned around. And I said, Mossep? And he turned around and said, who are you? And I said-- I said, Mossep, do you not remember me? He said, no. I said, Mossep, look upon real good. Remember me. He said, brethren, tell me who you is, man. Tell me who you is, man. Do you not remember Mario? Do you remember Mario? So, cannot forget Mario, man. Mario my brethren. Mario the first [SPEAKING JAMAICAN PATOIS] when I come to New York and the first man to get killed in front of me. He said, how could I not remember Mario? Mario was the first friend I had when I came to New York. And he's the first friend I ever had to be killed in front of me.
他转过身。我说：“莫塞普？”他转过身问：“你是谁？”我说：“莫塞普，你不记得我了吗？”他说：“不记得。”我说：“莫塞普，好好看看。记住我。”他说：“兄弟，告诉我你是谁，伙计。告诉我你是谁。你不记得马里奥了吗？你记得马里奥吗？”他说：“怎么可能忘了马里奥，兄弟。马里奥是我兄弟。马里奥是我刚到纽约时……第一个在我面前被杀的人。”他说：“我怎么会不记得马里奥？马里奥是我刚到纽约时交的第一个朋友。他是我第一个亲眼目睹被杀的朋友。”
Throughout that conversation, you know, I really couldn't look at him. You know, it just felt like someone just socked me right in the stomach, and then I literally bowled over because my stomach was hurting and cringed so bad, you know? So then I asked him, so why couldn't you do something, you know? He said, brethren, how you expect me to do something? I live amongst them. You know, they was sending threatening notes. They threw bottles through my window. And you got to remember, Johnny, you know, now we're big. Now we're men. Well, we weren't men. We thought we were men, but we were still kids.
在整个谈话过程中，你知道，我真的无法正视他。你知道，感觉就像有人往我胃里重重一击，我整个人弯下腰，因为胃痛得厉害，蜷缩起来，你知道吗？所以我问他：“那为什么你当时什么都没做，你知道吗？”他说：“兄弟，你怎么指望我做点什么？我住在这帮人中间。你知道，他们当时在寄恐吓信。他们往我窗户扔瓶子。你得记住，约翰尼，你知道，我们现在是成年人了。那时候我们不是大人，我们以为我们是，但我们还只是孩子。”
By January of 2001, three years after starting their reinvestigation, Carl and Robedee were ready to go back to court. They had tracked down and interviewed two eyewitnesses who hadn't testified at trial, two other witnesses who recanted their trial testimony. They'd gotten a confession from the real killer and sworn affidavits from three alibis. They gathered the new depositions and all the paperwork together in a brief so big the court clerks laughed when Carl brought it in.
到 2001 年 1 月，在开始重新调查三年后，卡尔和罗贝迪准备回到法庭。他们追踪并采访了两名庭审时未作证的目击者，以及两名撤回了庭审证词的证人。他们拿到了真凶的供词，以及三份不在场证明的宣誓书。他们将新的口供和所有文件汇总成一份简报，以至于当卡尔带过去时，法院书记员都笑了。
Robedee gathered everyone in his office/apartment and told them not to expect anything to happen for a while. It would take months to get a response from the court. But just four days later, Robedee's phone rang. It was Judge Leventhal from the state Supreme Court asking him to come in immediately for a conference. A couple of minutes later, Barry Schreiber, the assistant district attorney, called to ask the same thing.
罗贝迪把大家聚集在他的办公室兼公寓里，告诉他们不要指望短期内有什么结果。法院做出回应需要几个月。但仅仅四天后，罗贝迪的电话响了。是州最高法院的莱文塔尔法官打来的，要求他立即去参加会议。几分钟后，地方助理检察官巴里·施莱伯也打来电话提出同样要求。
And so I got to court about 4 o'clock in the afternoon, and Justice Leventhal called us up to the bench and Barry Schreiber was there. And he said, look, judge, we're not going to oppose the motion. As far as we're concerned, he didn't do it. I mean, I had no idea. I certainly wasn't prepared to win four days after I filed the motion. So I said-- so the judge looked at me and said, do you have an order prepared? No, judge. I'm not even sure what one's supposed to look like. He's like, well, write one, you know?
所以我下午 4 点左右到了法院，莱文塔尔法官叫我们上台，巴里·施莱伯也在。他说：“听着，法官，我们不反对这项动议。就我们而言，他没干那事。”我的天，我毫无准备。我当然没准备好在递交动议四天后就赢了。所以法官看着我说：“你有准备好的裁决令吗？”我说：“没有，法官。我甚至不知道那长什么样。”他就像说：“好吧，写一个。”
The next day Carl, Collin's wife, Robedee, and Shirley drove up to the prison and watched Collin emerge a free man.
第二天，卡尔、科林的妻子、罗贝迪和雪莉开车前往监狱，目送科林作为一个自由人出来。
They took me to the gate. Everybody was like at each window, yo, Collin! Yo, good luck! That feeling was so incredible, Anya. It was incredible because my wife always tells me that she had a dream, and she dreamed that she was with me at the prison gates. And I told her, well, that dream is not going to come true. There she is, waiting at the prison gates for me.
他们带我到大门口。每个人都在窗口喊：“哟，科林！哟，祝你好运！”那感觉太不可思议了，安雅。真的不可思议，因为我妻子总是告诉我她做了一个梦，梦见她和我在监狱大门口。我对她说：“那个梦是不会成真的。”但她就在那里，在那儿等着我。
After 21 years, of course, it's not over when you walk out of the prison gates. It took Collin almost a year to leave the house alone. He says he still feels more comfortable in small places with the door locked behind him. To this day, all his dreams still take place in prison, and if not, they end up there.
当然，21 年后，走出监狱大门并不意味着一切都结束了。科林花了将近一年时间才敢独自出门。他说他仍然觉得在狭小的地方且门锁好后感觉更自在。直到今天，他所有的梦境仍然发生在监狱里，如果不是，最终也会在那里结束。
While he was locked up, his father died. His sister got married. Everyone had kids. He says he feels like he was born in prison. He literally has no memory of his life before. And he says that in prison, when he imagined life outside, everything was clean and beautiful, and it was a little startling to discover that the outside world can be pretty grimy. He spent a lot of time trying to understand why did this happen to him? Why did the universe choose him to suffer so arbitrarily? He still hasn't figured it out.
在他被关押期间，他父亲去世了，他姐妹结婚了，每个人都有了孩子。他说他感觉自己就像是在监狱里出生一样。他确实对入狱前的人生毫无记忆。他说在监狱里，当他想象外面的生活时，一切都是干净美好的，所以发现外面的世界其实相当肮脏时，他感到有点震惊。他花了大量时间试图理解为什么会发生在他身上？为什么宇宙选择他如此任意地受苦？他至今没想明白。
Two days after Collin's release, his family planned a party for him. There was music, tables full of food, a lot of people Collin hadn't seen for over 20 years, and one person he'd never met, Martell Hamilton, whose brother's murder started this whole story and who told the cops what they wanted to hear and helped them build their case against Collin. When Martell walked in, a hush came over the room. Here's William Robedee.
科林获释两天后，他的家人为他举行了派对。有音乐，摆满食物的桌子，许多科林 20 多年来没见过的人，还有一个人他从未见过——马特尔·汉密尔顿。正是马特尔弟弟的谋杀案开启了整个故事，也是马特尔告诉警察他们想听的谎话，帮助他们建立了针对科林的案子。当马特尔走进来时，房间里安静了下来。威廉·罗贝迪说：
Collin was still within this religious period of purification where he was wearing white every day. So he had these big dreadlocks down and the white garment, the beard, a little moustache. I mean, looking everything in the world like Jesus off a stained glass window. And Martell literally broke down and started crying, and Collin went over to him and put his arm around him, and Collin was the one comforting him.
科林当时还处在宗教净化期，每天穿着白衣服。他留着长长的发辫，穿着白色长袍，留着胡须和小胡子。我的意思是，看起来就像彩色玻璃窗上走下来的耶稣。马特尔当时就崩溃了，开始哭，科林走过去搂住他，反倒是科林在安慰他。
Collin hugged me. And I hugged him back, and some tears-- some tears fell. And he said, brethren, oh, it feels so good seeing you.
科林拥抱了我。我也拥抱了他，眼泪……眼泪掉了下来。他说：“兄弟，见到你感觉真好。”
I hugged Martell because in the end, he did came forward and tried to rectify what he knew was wrong.
我拥抱了马特尔，因为最终，他站了出来，试图纠正他知道是错误的那些事。
Even though before his release we never spoke to each other, we somewhat had like a connection. And he said, I want to tell you, you know, I didn't know-- I didn't know your brother, but I knew him spiritually afterwards. He said, there was many nights in bed I said, I don't know why am I here and what did I do? But I used to pray to Mario and hope Mario was at peace.
尽管在释放前我们从未说过话，但我们之间有一种连接。他说：“我想告诉你，你知道，我当时不认识你兄弟，但我事后从精神上认识了他。”他说：“有很多个夜晚，我躺在床上心想：为什么我会在这里？我做了什么？但我曾向马里奥祈祷，希望马里奥安息。”
It was something I had never seen before other than, you know, certainly not in my real life with real people with real situations. It's something you hear about in books about saints doing it or something, that Collin was able to do what he did and that Martell actually had the courage to walk in there and ask him for the forgiveness.
这是一种我从未见过的情景，当然，在我的现实生活中，在有真人的真实情境里没见过。这就像你在书中看到的关于圣人会做的那种事，科林能够做到他所做的事，而马特尔居然有勇气走进去寻求他的宽恕。
Carl King likes to tell you and anyone who'll listen that individuals can make a difference, that justice is the only thing worth fighting for, that the little man can fight the system and win. And in this case, he was right. It just took a long time. There was a lot to fix. The police, for whatever reason, ignored the witnesses who said Collin had nothing to do with the murder and rushed to make the arrest stick. The DA looked past the contradictions in Thomas Charlemagne's testimony and proposed a theory of the murder that didn't match the forensic evidence.
卡尔·金喜欢对你和任何愿意听的人说，个人是可以产生影响的，正义是唯一值得奋斗的东西，小人物可以对抗体制并获胜。在这个案子里，他是对的。只是花费了很长时间。有很多需要修复的地方。警察出于某种原因，无视了那些说科林与谋杀无关的证人，急于让逮捕成立。地区检察官无视了托马斯·查理曼证词中的矛盾，并提出了一个根本不符合法医证据的谋杀理论。
Maybe everyone was overburdened. Maybe they just didn't care. There's nothing unusual about cases with so little evidence, says William Robedee.
也许每个人都负担过重。也许他们根本不在乎。威廉·罗贝迪说，证据如此稀少的案件并不少见。
It's not that uncommon that you won't have a murder weapon. It's not that uncommon that there will be no forensic evidence. It's not that uncommon that the only witness you'll have will be a career crackhead. People watch CSI, for example, and they think that's what goes on every time there's a murder, that these amazing teams of scientists swoop down out of everywhere and spend every possible hour and expend every possible dollar to make sure they have the right guy. That doesn't happen. And it should.
没有找回凶器并不是什么罕见的事。没有法医证据也不是罕见的事。唯一的证人是一个吸毒成瘾者也不是什么罕见的事。人们看《犯罪现场调查》之类的节目，认为每次谋杀都会发生那种事，那些神奇的科学家团队从天而降，花上每一刻可能的时间和每一分可能花的钱来确保抓到对的人。那种事并没有发生。而那本该发生。
You can't have a situation where an assistant district attorney has 80 or 90 felony prosecutions to be responsible for at any given moment because they will not have the time to spend on doing their job right. The same thing could be said for a homicide detective. I mean, the last comment I'll make about this is that if Collin Warner had lived in Texas or Florida or Louisiana, he would have been dead a long time ago. And that would have been the end of it.
你不能让助理地区检察官在任何时候都承担 80 或 90 起重罪起诉，因为他们根本没有时间去把工作做好。同样的话也适用于凶杀案侦探。我的意思是，我要做的最后一个评论是，如果科林·华纳住在德克萨斯州、佛罗里达州或路易斯安那州，他早就被处决了。那一切也就随之结束了。
So why did it take an amateur detective, a murderer, a housing lawyer working out of his apartment, and a bunch of grown-up kids from the old neighborhood to see that justice was done? In the end, perhaps the one thing Carl was willing to invest that police and lawyers and the overburdened criminal justice system weren't was time. Nobody wants to see an innocent man in prison, but only Carl King was willing to spend 21 years to get him out.
那么，为什么需要一名业余侦探、一名杀人犯、一名在公寓办公的住房律师，还有一群来自老街区长大的孩子们，才能让正义得到伸张呢？最后，也许卡尔愿意投入而警察、律师和过载的刑事司法系统不愿意投入的唯一东西就是时间。没人愿意看到无辜者在狱中，但只有卡尔·金愿意花费 21 年时间把他救出来。
Anya Bourg, she's a producer at Frontline. Collin now lives in Georgia with his wife and daughter. Carl's still in New York still working cases to exonerate the falsely imprisoned. A film was just released about their story. It's called Crown Heights, directed by Matt Ruskin, starring Lakeith Stanfield and Nnamdi Asomugha. [MUSIC - SINGLE MINDED PROS]
安雅·布尔格，她是《前线》的制作人。科林现在和妻子女儿住在乔治亚州。卡尔还在纽约处理案子，为被冤入狱者平反。关于他们的故事刚发行了一部电影，名为《皇冠高地》，由马特·拉斯金导演，勒凯斯·斯坦菲尔德和恩纳姆迪·阿萨穆哈主演。
Our program today was produced back in 2005 by Alex Blumberg and myself with Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Marie, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer for this episode was Julie Snyder. Production help from BA Parker. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. The music with the bells in today's program was produced for our show by DJ Rude 1. Single Minded Pros. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Special thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我们今天的节目是由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我自己在 2005 年制作的，戴安·库克、温迪·多尔、简·玛丽、萨拉·凯尼格和丽莎·波拉克共同参与。这一集的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。BA 帕克的制作协助。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。今天节目中带钟声的音乐是由 DJ Rude 1 为我们的节目制作的。Single Minded Pros。我们的网站：thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心 PRX 发送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，特别感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。